on November the 12th 2014 the rosetta
mission landed a probe on a comet 500
million kilometres from Earth in the
year that followed the Rosetta
spacecraft stream back mountains of data
from comet churyumov-gerasimenko also
known as 67p and the scientists back
home have made some amazing discoveries
Rosetta scientists were expecting a dull
potato shaped comet what they got was a
dusty ice ball shaped like a rubber duck
so how did it end up like this
photos of eroded patches on the surface
reveals onion-like layers of dust and
ice these concentric layers surround two
different center points one in each lobe
of the comet this suggests that the
comet was formed from the collision of
two smaller fragments hence its peculiar
shape
huge Jets of gas pouring out of the icy
comet give clues to its age Rosetta has
been able to analyze the different gases
in these Jets many of which would have
been trapped inside from when the comet
first formed the way the gases are
released all mixed together point to the
comet being made of a certain kind of
ice this could only have been formed in
extremely cold conditions perhaps even
before the solar system began this is
just one of a number of observations
which hint that 67p may be very old
indeed comets the mostly made of ice and
there's a long-standing theory that it
was comets that brought water to Planet
Earth
but the water vapor coming off 67p isn't
like ours at all compared to normal h2o
on earth a lot of the hydrogen atoms in
67 peas water have an extra Neutron
making them deuterium the ratio of
hydrogen to deuterium doesn't match
Earth's at all meaning that wherever our
vast oceans came from it wasn't comets
like 67p a year's worth of data from
Rosetta has answered a lot of questions
but the missions not over yet and
there's plenty still left to learn
density measurements show that 67p is
surprisingly light and fluffy but
despite being less dense than styrofoam
the surface is rock-hard so hard
the Rosetta's probe perhaps doff it and
couldn't even crack it with a hammer
can we work out how 67p can at the same
time be fluffy like snow and hard as
solid ice there aren't a lot of oxygen
molecules in outer space which is why it
was such a surprise to find so many
coming out of 67p how all that oh two
ended up there is still a mystery but
finding it could change our ideas about
how the solar system formed
scientists have previously studied a
comic called Hartley 2 which is in a
similar orbit 67p but the water on
Hartley 2 has a very different ratio of
deuterium to hydrogen compared to the
water on 67p so even though they ended
up close together did these sister
comets perhaps start out in completely
different places with all these
questions there's a lot to keep Rosetta
busy the spacecraft has less than a year
left before its journey ends with a
dramatic crash on the surface of the
comet but that's still plenty of time
for Rosetta teachers even more about
Comet 67p
you